why was i expelled from school
was it a putting a fish in my
headmaster's desk
b dyeing my hair bright red or c
stealing and reselling hardcore porn
magazines
what
hi i'm zoe kravitz
i'm robert pattinson
and this is do you even know me with lad
bible in 2014 what do they have named
after me a kissing technique a ben and
jerry's flavor or an asteroid oh i hope
it's a ben and jerry's flavor what is it
an asteroid what
really i had an asteroid oh my god i
haven't made it
what was it named
do you remember
well you don't even know yourself it was
246789 pattinson
that's what they named it
[Laughter]
of these options which is a hobby of
mine
trainspotting juggling
or crochet
juggling
i love that you think that of me
it's crochet
i know how to crochet
i can teach you later
why was i expelled from school
was it a treading of fish in my
headmaster's desk
b dyeing my hair bright red or c
stealing and reselling hardcore porn
magazines
what
[Music]
what were the first two putting a fish
in my headmaster's pants
dying my
pubes bright red you didn't say that it
kinda confuses me
your hair
no
stealing porno magazines and some of
them you know what i wanted to say that
and then i was i don't know i don't know
disgusting you're dirty i just made that
from the festive
filming this year i am making my
directorial debut what is the name of
the film a
puppy palace
or
[ __ ] island
i thought it's puppy [ __ ] puppy [ __ ]
is correct
what is it
it's the island that's fine
what harry potter house was my character
cedric diggory in will you do there's no
options
and i gotta get it gave up on the
multiple choice
i have no idea
i know i'm sorry i'm i'm sorry
hufflepuff
okay what did i want to be as a child a
ballerina
b
a spy c
a librarian
it's actually quite tough
a
librarian what
i can't see that
crochet
yeah crocheting librarian no a spy
[Laughter]
is that really the question yeah
this is horrible are they they're brown
oh my gosh that's insane that is
actually too much
oh they're like a dark
what are
they no no but truly they're not they're
like are they blue
they're not surrounded
okay oh my god
which british band first made me
starstruck a led zeppelin be the rolling
stones or see the spice girls spice goes
for sure
that's so obvious
why did you like them so much
everyone liked them the spice girls were
everything they were everything
well that's it rob won what whatever
that was great guys thank you
puppy [ __ ]
you don't like gloves don't love gloves
worming your hand into a glove i'm just
like ha ha i don't like it but wait did
you wear gloves in mary poppins didn't
you yeah and it was tough it was tough
i'm not gonna lie i took them off
whenever i could really was it tough it
was really cool it was really tough for
you
for me it was really hard really hard
you should toughen up